News is not good in Toronto where
investigators are not ruling out
terrorism in a deadly shooting spree in
North America's fourth largest city
police are examining this video that
appears to show a man with a gun opening
fire last night in a Toronto street
filled with restaurants the second
person has now died taking the death
toll to 212 other people were wounded
the suspect is dead after exchanging
gunfire with officers the area was
filled with families gathered for Sunday
night dinners Tony de copal is here
following the investigation Tony good
morning good morning authorities are
hoping locals will turn in any video
recording devices they may have set up
along the street that could give police
a better understanding of last night's
attack and what an attack it was
witnesses described a man walking up and
down the sidewalk pointing a gun
directly in a crowded restaurants and
cafes and firing cell phone video
appears to show the alleged shooter
dressed in black and armed with a
handgun the first 911 calls went out
around 10:00 p.m. witnesses say they
heard 28 to 30 gunshots I thought it was
fireworks at first because it was a
rapid-fire clip being spent reloading
clipping spent reloading clip being
spent that's what I heard
first responders quickly swarmed the
area and engaged the suspect there was
an exchange of gunfire and Toronto
Police Chief Mark Saunders says the
suspect died from gunshot wounds he says
it's too soon to know the shooters
motives but that the attack was not
random the attack took place in
Toronto's Greektown neighborhood which
investigators hope will help them in
their search for evidence we've got
numerous witnesses that are here any
types of cameras that are going to be
available dash cams that may be in the
neighborhood so I'm hoping that there
are more avenues and more opportunities
for us to get those small pieces of the
puzzle local lawmakers say the attack on
such a family-friendly area is
particularly disturbing this is a street
where people walk every day to go do to
their groceries to have dinner to have
an ice-cream sit in the square enjoy
their summer and it's absolutely
devastating devastating indeed though
gun violence on this scale is rare in
two in Toronto over the weekend dozens
of additional police officers were
deployed to combat a recent spike in
shootings now two city councilors say
the attacker in this shooting was
emotionally disturbed which may seem
self-evident but that has not been
confirmed by police John
Toni thank you